if anything the protests in Iran are
stepping up despite the government's
attempts to crack down on them often
with lethal violence
there is a noticeable generational
divide to this Uprising it's young
against old
this video shows female students in
Shiraz shouting besieges get lost
to a member of the feared besiji
paramilitary Force who had been invited
to give a speech
and in this video filmed near the cap of
Tehran Iranian schoolgirls many without
their heads covered throw objects at a
man and chase him away
foreign
actresses around the world have been
cutting their hair in protest at the way
women are treated by the Iranian regime
[Music]
and in the European Parliament in
Brussels an iraqi-born Swedish MEP cut
off part of her hair in solidarity with
the women of Iran Ian
Azadi women life freedom I will always
have Hope and Faith in the people of
Iran and especially in the women of Iran
the feminist movement is not born
yesterday or three weeks ago the
feminist movement is over 100 years old
and I am convinced that history will
change either with force or with cutting
of our hairs
the uprising started after the death of
22 year old Masa amini who died in
custody after being arrested for not
wearing her hijab correctly
but the protests are no longer just
about head coverings they're about
freedoms and rights in the face of a
repressive regime
alistabunkel Sky News